el Grupo Mercenario Wagner estaría
detrás de la ofensiva en macmut según un
observadores de guerra y autoridades de
Ucrania allí los ucranianos resisten yo
solo no
la situación es difícil pero sigue
siendo Bueno
estamos aquí estamos trabajando es
difícil para la ciudad y los habitantes
locales pero estamos aquí
con el presidente boludimir selensky las
batallas más feroces se llevan a cabo en
la región de donetsk mientras en
crasnojorisca Ciudad da un controlada
por Ucrania las autoridades les llevaron
a los residentes artículos de primera
necesidad en esta ciudad los bombardeos
han dejado destrucción a su paso las
casas han sido dañadas o están cubiertas
de agujeros de bala al norte de gerson
otro panorama la contraofensiva
ucraniana busca retomar la ciudad que
cayó en manos rusas hace meses el
enemigo está Aproximadamente a 2,5
kilómetros de nuestras posiciones a las
11 horas hoy nuestras posiciones están
tripuladas por soldados muy motivados
saben Por qué están aquí para servir
para cumplir tareas la pérdida de la
ciudad sería otra de las derrotas para
el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin quien
anexionó gerson y otras tres regiones en
unas elecciones criticadas por occidente
en una intervención siguió echando leña
al fuego a las ya tensas relaciones
la dominación mundial es a lo que
apuesta el presidente en su juego pero
ese juego es sin duda un juego peligroso
sangriento y diría inmundo
Moscú ha estado difundiendo rumores
sobre una supuesta bomba sucia que
estaría construyendo kiev lo que podría
ser una excusa del kremlin para atacar
Ucrania con artefactos atómicos y así
evitar perder el control sobre las
regiones anexadas en Ucrania